Vladimir Putin ya ha conquistado un país entero.
Y lo ha hecho sin disparar ni un sólo tiro ¡Habéis
oído bien! Mientras todos el mundo habla de
Ucrania, hay otro país que ha caído totalmente
en manos de Rusia sin que pocos se hayan
dado cuenta ¿De qué país estamos hablando?
¡Exacto! Bielorrusia.
Para quien no lo conozca, hablamos de la última
dictadura de Europa. Esto no lo decimos nosotros:
lo reconoce el propio presidente de
Bielorrusia, Alexander Lukashenka. Atentos.
El gobierno autoritario es algo
propio de mí. Siempre lo he admitido.
“Es mejor ser dictador que ser
gay” –Alexander Lukashenka
En otras palabras: Bielorrusia es una dictadura
salvaje. Pero... ¿Por qué decimos que Putin les
ha conquistado? Pues atentos.
El 27 de Febrero de 2022,
Bielorrusia aprobó un cambio sustancial en su
Constitución. Lo hizo a través de un referéndum
con todas las garantías democráticas que
caben esperar de un país como Bielorrusia:
es decir, NINGUNA. Con estas nuevas enmiendas,
Bielorrusia permitirá a Rusia establecer bases
nucleares en su territorio. Territorio donde ya
se han establecido miles de tropas rusas para
desplegarse en Ucrania. En el terreno político y
económico, Bielorrusia ya ha firmado acuerdos con
Rusia para tener políticas comunes en materias
como impuestos, finanzas y política industrial.
El objetivo final es terminar formando el
llamado “Estado Unido”, es decir, que Bielorrusia
termine formando una unión política con Rusia.
Os lo hemos contado en anteriores capítulos de
VisualPolitik: el Kremlin siempre ha soñado con
anexionarse Bielorrusia. Esto viene de antes,
incluso, de que Putin llegara
a Presidente. Sin embargo,
el dictador Bielorruso, Lukashenka, siempre
se había mostrado muy reticente a esta unión.
Ahora las cosas han cambiado. Podemos decir que
Lukashenka le debe su supervivencia política a
Putin. La guerra de Ucrania ha sido sólo
el pretexto para avanzar más rápido en la
anexión. Sí, es cierto, Moscú se está
desangrando económica y militarmente.
La guerra de Ucrania ha sido una decisión
calamitosa en casi todos los frentes. Pero,
tenemos que ser justos, en lo que respecta a
Bielorrusia, Putin se puede anotar un éxito.
La pregunta ahora es... ¿Qué pasaría
si Lukashenka cayera? Mejor aún ¿Qué
pasaría si el apoyo de Putin fuera lo
que hiciera caer a Lukashenka? Atentos.
Protestas masivas contra la guerra
en Bielorrusia: 800 detenidos
¡Pero esperad un momento! No
sólo hablamos de protestas.
Los ciudadanos de Bielorrusia están
haciendo todo lo posible por parar la
guerra de Ucrania. Y sí, hablamos de mucho
más que protestas. Mirad esta noticia.
Las conexiones de ferrocarril entre
Bielorrusia y Ucrania se han saboteado
para impedir el paso de las tropas rusas
Hablamos de grupos organizados para hacer
la vida imposible a las tropas rusas estacionadas
en Bielorrusia. Y no son pocos. En estos momentos,
podemos decir que Lukashenka tiene a casi
toda la sociedad en contra. La pregunta es
¿Qué pasa con su ejército? Pensadlo bien:
un dictador como Lukashenka necesita tener
a sus fuerzas armadas bajo control ¿Qué
pasaría si lo perdiera? ¿De verdad es
posible que Bielorrusia caiga de las manos
de Putin... justo ahora que está a punto de
convertirse en una región de Rusia? Hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes...
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL SILICON VALLEY SOVIÉTICO
¿Os suena un videojuego que se llama “World of
Tanks”? Seguro que muchos lo habréis jugado. O lo
habréis oído mencionar en algún canal de YouTube.
Se trata de uno de los videojuegos más populares
de los últimos años. Lo que seguramente no sepáis
es que este juego está hecho... ¡En Bielorrusia!
¡Habéis oído bien! Y no, no se trata de una
empresa estadounidense con oficinas en Minsk. La
empresa que desarrolla World of Tanks fue fundada
con capital bielorruso y tenía sus oficinas
centrales en la capital del país. Todo esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que Bielorrusia
es una dictadura con poco más de 9 millones de
habitantes. Pero hablamos de un país más rico de
lo que parece. Vamos a decirlo claro, Lukashenka
puede ser un dictador abominable pero... ¡No es
tonto! Desde que llegó al poder en 1994, se
aseguró de lograr 3 objetivos: estabilidad
económica, paz y soberanía. Y, en cierto modo,
lo ha logrado. Podríamos decir que Bielorrusia
pertenece al grupo de ex repúblicas soviéticas
que ni siquiera intentaron hacer una transición al
capitalismo. Se puede ver incluso en sus símbolos
nacionales, que mantienen la estética soviética.
De hecho, el Partido Comunista sigue
formando parte del Gobierno. A diferencia
de Rusia o Ucrania, Bielorrusia ni siquiera
se planteó un proceso de privatizaciones. A
día de hoy, más del 50% de su PIB está en manos
de empresas estatales. El Estado controla los
sectores más importantes, desde el gas que viene
de Rusia hasta la principal exportación del país:
el potasio, que se utiliza para fabricar
fertilizantes ¡Habéis oído bien! En muchos
aspectos, Bielorrusia sigue anclada en la
Unión Soviética. Como os podéis imaginar,
Rusia es el principal socio comercial del país.
Con este panorama, muchos pensaréis que este país
siempre ha sido un títere del Kremlin ¿Verdad?
Sin embargo ¡Nada más lejos de la realidad!
No importa quien venga a las tierras
bielorrusas, yo lo voy a combatir...
incluso si es Putin –Alexander Lukashenka
¡Habéis oído bien! Lukashenka puede ser un
aliado de Putin... pero no es un títere. De
hecho, su política ha sido muy pragmática. Sí,
es cierto, la economía mantiene un sistema
medio comunista y muy conectado con Rusia.
Pero también han recibido toda clase de ayudas
financieras de la Unión Europea ¡Y no sólo eso!
Al más puro estilo del Comunismo Chino, Lukashenka
también ha creado Zonas Económicas Especiales.
Aquí es donde entra el famoso “High TechIndustrial
Park”, creado en el año 2005. Se trata de un
intento para crear un pequeño Silicon Valley
versión soviética. Las empresas de este parque
industrial están exentas de pagar impuestos
de sociedades. Tampoco pagan impuestos de
bienes inmuebles. Y los trabajadores tienen
un tipo lineal de impuesto de la renta del 9%.
Y diréis ¿De verdad ha funcionado este Silicon
Valley soviético? Pues lo cierto es que sí. Para
que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2018, el
High Tech Industrial Park ya contaba con 388
empresas tecnológicas que daban trabajo a 30.000
personas. Aquí es donde nació el World of Tanks,
entre otros muchos juegos. Puede pareceros
un detalle sin importancia. Pero recordad que
hablamos de un país de renta baja con 9 millones
de habitantes. Sólo este parque industrial supone
más del 1.5% de todo el PIB del país. Dicho
de otra forma: podemos burlarnos de Lukashenko
todo lo que queramos. Pero ha conseguido
lo que ni siquiera Putin fue capaz: tener
una industria tecnológica competitiva a nivel
internacional. Y de hecho, atentos a esta gráfica.
Si os fijáis, veréis que Bielorrusia
es casi el doble de rica que Ucrania.
Y esta comparativa es dolorosa. Ucrania
es un país corrupto, sí, pero, al menos,
intentó desarrollar una democracia. Con todas
sus imperfecciones, los Ucranianos han podido
disfrutar de cierta libertad. Bielorrusia ni
siquiera se ha esforzado en mantener la más
mínima pose democrática. Es una dictadura. Punto.
Sin embargo, en el campo económico, parece que el
modelo bielorruso ha funcionado mejor. En otras
palabras: ha sido capaz de dar lo que prometía;
estabilidad económica. La pregunta es ¿Hasta
cuando va a durar? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
DUELO DE MACHOS ALFA
En el año 1990, Bielorrusia se
independizó de la Unión Soviética.
En 1994, redactaron su constitución y Lukashenka
se convirtió en dictador del país. Sin embargo, en
1997, el por presidente ruso, Boris Yeltsin, firmó
el “Tratado para el Estado Unido” con Alexander
Lukashenka. Este tratado era un intento para unir
Rusia y Bielorrusia en una entidad supraestatal.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, esto es el tipo de
cosas que no le hacen gracia a ningún dictador.
A fin de cuentas, todo buen dictador quiere poder
mandar sobre su país sin ningún tipo de ataduras.
Ni dentro ni fuera de sus fronteras. En el momento
en el que firmas un acuerdo con otro mucho más
grande que tú, ya no puedes hacer lo que quieras
¿Conclusión? Lukashenka le dijo a Yeltsin: Mira,
Boris Yeltsin, yo te firmo lo que quieras. Los
rusos y los bielorrusos somos primos hermanos...
vamos juntos de la mano... Pero lo de juntarnos
en un Estado ya lo vamos viendo. Ahora es que
me viene muy mal... tengo mucho lío estos días.
Ya, si eso... dentro de unos años lo miramos.
Y esta ha sido la postura de Bielorrusia
durante décadas... ¡Hasta que llegó este señor!
¡Exacto! Vladimir Putin. Y, como ya sabéis,
si a Putin se le mete algo en la cabeza,
no se le puede convencer de lo contrario. Por el
año 2019, Putin le llegó a Lukashenko y le dijo:
--Oye, Alexander, majete... he estado
mirando unos papeles viejos por aquí y
tenemos un acuerdo firmado...
--Uy! El acuerdo
de asociación... ¡Ya ni me acordaba! Lo firmé con
Yeltsin, ya sabes... Yeltsin... (GESTO DE BEBER)
--¡Alexander Lukashenka! ¡O Lukashenko!
O como sea que se pronuncie tu apellido.
Aquí tenemos un acuerdo firmado y ya
estás tardando en unirte a la Madre Rusia.
Y así es como las relaciones entre Bielorrusia
y Rusia se empezaron a torcer. Os lo contamos
en un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción. Putin
y Lukashenka se enzarzaron en todo un duelo de
“machos alfa”. Putin amenazó con cortar el
suministro de gas. Lukashenka amenazó con
robar el gas a Rusia. Literalmente. Incluso
llegó a hacer guiños al mismísimo Estados
Unidos. Parecía que estos dos países estaban a
punto de convertirse en enemigos. Y entonces,
ocurrió lo siguiente. Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL PUEBLO UNIDO... YA HA SIDO VENCIDO
En el año 2020, Bielorrusia convocó elecciones
¡Tranquilos! Esto no significa que se convirtieran
en una democracia. Las elecciones en Bielorrusia
son tan falsas que ni siquiera se esfuerzan
en ocultar que hacen trampas. En este caso,
Lukashenko estaba listo para volver a “ganar las
elecciones” por nada menos que un 80% del voto.
Pero, en este caso, las oposición estaba realmente
organizada. Y las calles de Minsk se llenaron
de manifestantes. Para que os hagáis una idea,
la policía de Lukashenka llegó a meter en la
cárcel a más 6000 manifestantes. Y la lideresa
de la oposición, Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya,
se marchó al exilio en Lituania. Desde ahí,
se ha convertido en todo un símbolo internacional.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¡El pueblo
Bielorruso se ha unido! ¡Los días del dictador
están contados! Pues no. Siento defraudaros pero
Lukashenka sigue en el poder ¿Por qué? Primero
porque tiene el control del ejército y la policía.
Segundo porque la economía iba moderadamente
bien. Tercero porque, en el último momento,
apareció su hermano mayor a rescatarle.
Protestas de Bielorrusia: Putin está listo
para enviar apoyo militar a Lukashenko
¿Conclusión? Las cosas han seguido como
siempre en Bielorrusia. La Unión Europea dijo que
estaba muy “deeply conserned” con Bielorrusia. Y,
mientras tanto, World of Tanks se convirtió en
uno de los videojuegos más populares de Rusia.
Sin embargo... el año 2022 lo ha cambiado
todo ¿Por qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿PUEDE CAER LUKASHENKA?
La pregunta del millón de dólares en este
momento es ¿Hay tropas bielorrusas en Ucrania?
Ucrania dice que sí. Bielorrusia dice que NO. Que
de ningún modo. Que bajo ningún concepto enviarían
soldados a Ucrania. Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
Quiero decir, Lukashenka no es precisamente un
dictador con pelos en la lengua. Y Putin le ha
pedido ayuda. Las tropas rusas llevan más de un
año estacionadas en territorio bielorruso. Además,
Lukashenka acaba de aprobar una constitución
que pone a su país en manos de Rusia ¿Por qué no
manda a su ejército? O, al menos... ¿Por qué no se
atreve a decir abiertamente que lo hace? Atentos.
Deserciones y dimisiones en el
ejército bielorruso previnieron
que el país se uniera a la invasión de Ucrania
¡Ojo! Puede que esta noticia no sea cierta. No
deja de ser información que ha dado la oposición
bielorrusa. Pero lo cierto es que todo apunta
a que es cierto. Según varias fuentes, incluso
el Jefe del Alto Estado Mayor habría dimitido.
Pensadlo así: una cosa es apoyar a un dictador
en tiempos de paz y dar algún que otro porrazo
a un disidente. Otra muy distinta es
entrar en una guerra suicida. Una cosa es
ser malo y otra es ser tonto.
Aunque ahora que lo pienso…
¿Hay tropas bielorrusas en Ucrania? En realidad,
la respuesta es que… ¡Sí! Oficialmente podemos
confirmar que en Ucrania hay tropas bielorrusas.
Ahora bien, no son las que os esperaríais.
Cientos de Bielorrusos se han unido a Ucrania
en la lucha contra el imperialismo ruso
¡Exacto! La oposición bielorrusa está mucho más
motivada que el ejército. Algunos se han ido a
luchar a Ucrania. Otros se han quedado
en el país haciendo cosas como esta.
Bielorrusia arresta a cuatro personas por intentar
sabotear los ferrocarriles que van para Ucrania
¡Ojo! Porque esto ya no son simples protestas.
Estamos hablando de una oposición muy motivada
y bien organizada ¡Pero no sólo eso! Con
o sin tropas en Ucrania, Bielorrusia ha
sufrido casi las mismas sanciones económicas
que Rusia. Y eso explica noticias como esta.
La empresa más grande de videojuegos
de Bielorrusia abandona el país
¡Y no son los únicos! Prácticamente todo ese
Silicon Valley soviético del que hablábamos
antes se está marchando. Y con el, todos
los trabajadores. Hablamos de empresas que
están moviendo todas sus plantillas a otros
lugares. Y recordad que Bielorrusia no tiene
gas natural ni petróleo ¿Conclusión? Alexander
Lukashenka está en una situación mucho peor,
incluso, que Vladimir Putin ¿No me
creéis? Pues fijaos en este gráfica.
A diferencia del rublo RUSO, el rublo Bielorruso
no se ha recuperado de la devaluación. Es decir,
han sufrido los efectos de las sanciones pero no
han sido capaces de hacer las maniobras monetarias
que ha hecho Moscú ¡Pero no sólo eso! A diferencia
de Putin, Lukashenko sí tiene una oposición muy
bien articulada ¿Quién sería el mayor opositor
de Putin? Probablemente Alexei Navalny que,
por mucho apoyo que tenga en Internet…
¡Está en la cárcel! En Bielorrusia,
la principal opositora de Lukashenko es
Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya, que ahora mismo
está entrevistándose con todos los líderes del
mundo. ¡Pero no sólo eso! A diferencia de Putin,
Lukashenka no tiene el apoyo incondicional del
ejército. Es difícil saber cuanta gente le apoya
y cuantos estarían dispuestos a levantarse contra
él. Pero está claro que no puede jugar con fuego.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿Puede
caer Alexander Lukashenka? ¿De verdad creéis que
Putin puede enviar muchas tropas para protegerlo,
ahora que casi todo su ejército está en Ucrania?
¿Es posible hacer algo desde Estados Unidos o
Europa para catalizar el fin de Lukashenka? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Recordad también visitar
nuestro nuevo canal hermano: VisualEconomik, donde
hablamos de nuestra otra gran pasión: la economía.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.